was bisher geschah der hochwart hallo
mein name ist khan herzlich willkommen
wir heute zu einer neuen folge war leute
wird schon jetzt auf dem server wir
haben es tatsächlich geschafft in mister
wargame entkommen
und wir haben wieder einen change euch
am start ich würd sagen drei zwei eins
und los auf dem server ich bin schon
drauf und schon angreifbar aber ich
denke uns wird keiner nachschauen und
vor allem das ding ist auch also juli
und seine freundin sind einfach direkt
neben uns gewesen
allerdings haben sie uns nicht gesehen
falls sie wissen wollen wie das ganze
passiert ist schaut euch aber die letzte
folge an und mein gott es ins paradies
ja man ok apropos essen ins paradies das
ist jetzt unsere oberste priorität
wir bauen erst mal einen ofen maxi
oberste priorität ist die heutige
challenge das stimmt natürlich
ich würde sagen hier bin habe ich an war
wohl so gemacht die erste folge wenn ich
du wäre folge wo wir unsere koordinaten
offenbart haben wo bist du nadal geht es
gut ich bin hier vorne weil hier noch
ein hühnchen ist drei münchen die erste
folge war eine wenn ich toure folge wo
wir unsere koordinaten unter anderem
offenbart haben
in der zweiten folge die ganze zeit
geschickt um vielseitig backpfeifen
gegeben mehr oder weniger weil wir immer
unterschiedliche wörter gesagt haben wo
ihr folgen sagt haben dass sie nicht
sagen dürfen und jetzt in der dritten
folge haben wir uns gedacht wir haben ja
so ein paar wäscheklammern ich bin
einfach mal ab und zu hygienischen
papier und damit ihr versteht wie das
geht würde ich sagen machen wir es
direkt mal und zwar schreibt eine wahl
in den chat 3 2 1 1 jetzt muss ich mir
die wäscheklammer irgendwo ins gesicht
knipsen und die für den rest der
aufnahme am körper ich habe jetzt mein
rechtes ohr gewählt ok lokalen ja mit
dem müssen wir mal ein hühnchen rupfen
witz was ich jetzt mal ein nein ich bin
durch kann ich dafür gar nicht mehr
blenden
ich bin lacht keine ahnung hier sind
schaut euch einfach max folge an wenn
ihr das sehen wollt ja genau leute
schaut wohl noch ein bisschen holz und
sonne ja ok aber merkt ihr mal dass du
immer hierher zurückkommen zu wir müssen
jetzt auch noch was machen aus dem übrig
gebliebenen rohstoffen ich bin so happy
dass wir tatsächlich entkommen sind weil
er so ein spiel noch mal schere stein
papier würde ich sagen ich will nicht
nur ok 3321 schon wieder ich ja gewonnen
ja aber sicher der wäscheklammer die
schnauze ich denke ich habe mir extra
zehn stück holz die nase
da hatte ich noch mal ändern weil ich
habe jetzt schon die nase genommen du
hast nichts mehr ändern aber man hat
nicht so krass
okay das schon mal gut luca es gibt hier
gebraten ist schicken du brauchst du
auch noch was zu essen
ich hab dir schon drei stücken geworfen
ok so luca jetzt bist du aber mal dran
ich fordere dich noch mal heraus zu
schere stein papier weniger oder ihre
stein papier
ich nehme ich nehme aber die nase kommen
wenn du schon leider werde ich auch mein
gott sind die engen das ist erzählt dass
gegen das passt nicht meine nase bei mir
doch auch nicht bei mir doch auch nicht
hey leute in diesem video zeige ich euch
einfach mal fehlen einer
zufallsgenerierte welt in minecraft eure
ersten diamanten innerhalb von nur fünf
minuten findet ich kann ich war die
schlucken
aber leute luca klingt original wie
seinem ersten video
komm lass mal ein bisschen umziehen
ich meine wir sind jetzt da wo die ruby
lassen
stein papier notieren alter wollt wir
müssen die wegschieben von der nase zu
weh weil wir auch sagen dass wir gleich
wo bist du über dir läuft nun mal vor
genau die brauchen wir brauchen eine
höhle wir müssen jetzt wirklich mal
schaffen diese folge von einem zu
bekommen die anderen haben
wahrscheinlich schon all die erst jetzt
ja okay also bist du hinter mir
wir müssen wir dürfen uns nicht
verlieren
folge folgt ich bin hinter dir wir
suchen jetzt erstmal die höhe
wenn ich mich so so rede ich halt
wirklich normal wenn ich mich jetzt
nicht irgendwie anstrengend nicht durch
die nase auszuatmen beim reden lorig
schränkt mich überhaupt nicht an so
wenig auch noch mal einfach voll zu
greifen es tut noch ziemlich weh
eine einfache ja also wir brauchen wir
brauchen vor allen dingen wirklich eine
natürliche höhle weil sonst haben ein
ziemliches problem glaube ich und es
wird auch gerade nacht luca wo bist du
denn da hier rechts hinter dir hinter
dir
okay da gibst du wissen mitnehmen
auch hier ist es eine höhle
das ist alles kein höhe sind nur
wasserlöcher papierkorb ok schere stein
papier anderes ich glaube da vorne vor
den zombies wirklich dann legen wir mal
ich hab halt immer noch kein bisschen
rüstung luca ist es so peinlich
eigentlich nach dem krieg bestimmt
ordentlich damage
[Musik]
ja ja sonst haben wir ein ziemlich
problem ok folgt mir mal bitte was die
kleinen scheiße ich glaube da vorne war
eine höhle okay es sind viel zu viele
monster hier bist du ja das sind auch
über als spinnen gott ich kann dir
sprinten
als sie weg von mir oder hast du lust
geräte essen doch was bitte schnell
erledigt was okay und hals diesmal hat
sie noch weg von mir fragt ob ich kann
ja nicht sprinten gerade okay jetzt kann
ich wieder schwinden ok wenn lukas ist
das achte vorsicht vorsicht vorsichtig
sein die die kann uns runterschubsen die
viecher ok sehr gut gespielt und ich hab
sie okay alles gute lage bei anlagen
ich brauche dringend rüstung da vorne
ist eine schäferei nicht luca also
erstmal wir brauchen unbedingt diese
folge von eilen wir haben noch acht
minuten das können wir eigentlich
schaffen ja ich baue das eisen ab schon
wie kohle bauernhöfen aufgebaut gerade
hier und steht eine da wurde ja ich hab
ein schwedischer 4 3 2 1
[Musik]
wir machen immer nur das gleiche alter
aber meine ohren fallen langsam ab alter
bist du richtig packen ist das einzige
rein 28 eisen alltag schelbert
krass so muss das war hier glaubt noch
was irgendwo an der decke so jung wie
mache ich die behinderten ware videos es
ist nicht mehr dabei gerade bei uns ja
ich habe kräftig table hier ans ohr hast
du sie erst angepackt dugan
ich hab das einzige reingepackt ich
musste ans team denken
ich mache den harisch na ja bitte hier
wir sind ziemlich viele mops ok wat ich
ziehe mich erst mal kurz zurück
ich komme ja ich komme zurück hast du
noch einen spinnen farben 2 ok gibst du
mir mal danke schön ja auf mich war der
üppige pult stein papier gab es übrigens
nicht gesehen auch wenn ich danach erst
getippt habe meine nase vw hier noch
keinen bogen
ihre beine da sie tut so weh ich habe
den bogen geben ja man natürlich auch so
will ich habe 26 links hell wie ging
nochmal
auch das kohle was okay ich hab das
falsche ja ich glaube ich habe mir erst
mal alles leer gemacht wir müssen tiefer
würde ich sagen
oder wie viel essen haben wir noch
relativ viel also ich würde sagen wir
haben einigermaßen vernünftig aufgeholt
gerade wenn man bedenkt dass wir nur
scheiße machen die ganze zeit darauf ist
klar ich hätte gedacht dass ein
schlechter darauf erstmal schere stein
papier
okay ich mache auch alltag gibt sich
meine nase an leute okay man sieht nicht
so krass aber ich probiere mal dass
manchmal doch es ist auch probieren ein
nasenloch ausschuss ist auch in eine
neue variation okay wir müssen irgendwie
tiefer rein lasst das alles abbauen oder
max ist noch alles sofort nicht bevor
wir nach dem stimmte auch schon mal die
krone auf so was ja stimmt
wo müssen wir keine zeit verschwenden ok
erst 33 dinge wir müssen noch locker ich
habe 32
dann lass mal zwei runden hintereinander
spielen jetzt okay ich höre was haben
wir aber okay wollen wir ja ok 328 spiel
ja ja 3 2 1 los
und noch eine runde direkt drei meine
ohren sowie 321 ich mach die das kind
ich hab es hingenommen
alter schwede guckt euch unbedingt auch
lukas perspektive an
so erinnert was wir machen
ok wollen hier packmaß und werkbank
mitnehmen okay die fällt ab ich muss mal
ich hab augenbrauen sich nicht mehr
wohin irgendwo weiter runter weiter
runter ja ich folge dir arbeite hier
geht es runter genommen ja ich bin da
jetzt aber also sollte ich mal die prior
sein
die brauchen ja das wäre krass alter
obwohl sowohl mit dem werkzeug auf der
auch leisten
du bist noch privates gerade auf mich
oder sehr gut
die anderen haben bestimmt aber also wir
hatten beide den eindruck als wir unser
material wo wir mister moore und harry
luck muss sah es aus als hätten die von
allen der sackgasse ja es ist ein anlass
einfach runter bauen lassen unter
ballast zurück durch die hürde
meinst du weiter geht's runter oder
wir haben noch eineinhalb minuten
wir werden im ergebnis einfach krass wie
wär's mit einer runde schere stein
papier auf das leben schwer ist alles so
wäre stein papier
ich koche steinstraße ich mache hier
habt ihr hier leihweise ein gutes
zeichen alter meine augen zu wie er sagt
klar weise gutes zeichen
ja weil aber sind doch oft diamanten
klar ist auch auf der tod okay was
machen wir jetzt
ich würde sagen ich mache mir tut auch
weh alter ja ich muss dann ab nämlich
wirklich gerne eine höhle
es tut so weh mir doch auch luca mir
doch auch da tut sich rw a
maxi kaders liegt das ich wusste ich
muss absagen dem abpfiff beim märchen
für kinder hast du verloren
ja ich hab verloren leute ich die mal
kurz zu festem meine ohren alter von den
scheiß klammern ey ich habe schneider
über alle meiner rechten com bekommen
kommen runter zu mir du besser wenn ich
hier stehe
du stehst du hast ja auch keine
spitzhacke mehr
mir tut alles weh weniger die
schmerzhafteste waro folge mein ort tut
richtig gut auch junge so etwas nicht
nochmal machen
nein leute wenn ihr übrigens ideen für
challenges habt könnt ihr uns ja und in
die kommentare schreiben sie was sie
beispielsweise spielt man mit
handschuhen oder hände über kreuz oder
irgendwas anderes was vielleicht nicht
so wie jetzt gerade aber dann erst mal
leute wenn euch die folge gefallen
lassen unlike da und schaut euch auf
jeden fall max folge alle dann würde ich
sagen sehen wir uns in der nächsten
folge biedermann wir sehen uns
[Musik]